[Musica]
da bambino sono cresciuto durante gli
anni 80 i bambini di oggi già si
preoccupano di globalizzazione di
cambiamento climatico
partecipano ai fridays for futures ma
quando ero bambino io mi dovevo
preoccupare soltanto di due cose la
prima era di andare d'accordo con mio
fratello non so se fosse stato un colpo
di genio dei miei genitori un caso
qualcosa di simile ma si erano accorti
che con dei giochi in scatola avrebbero
tolto ogni ritito bisogna giocare
insieme spendevamo le ore a giocare ai
titoli dell'epoca brivido l'isola di
fuoco hero quest sono diventati da quel
momento sono rimasti per il resto la
nostra vita una delle nostre grandissime
passioni la seconda preoccupazione che
avevo era relativa alla moda del periodo
c'era qualcosa in questa omologazione
nei paninari nei vestiti tutti uguali
nel non poter guardare un cartone
animato senza sentire la voce di
cristina d'avena ecco c'era qualcosa che
mi metteva profondamente a disagio
ho finito per trovare un pò per scelta
forse un po per destino e la mia via nel
appassionarmi ai computer ai giochi alla
scienza temi che mi hanno accompagnato
per il resto della mia vita insomma sono
diventato un nerd e essere un nerd negli
anni ottanta è stata anche una grande
fortuna perché mi ha permesso di
conoscere di vivere in prima persona un
sacco di evoluzioni dell'informatica da
allora fino ad oggi
vedete non c'è appassionato di computer
della mia generazione che non abbia
visto questo film war games
in pratica per chi di voi non lo conosce
un hacker riesce ad infiltrarsi in un
supercomputer della difesa americana e
fa partire un gioco una simulazione
della guerra termonucleare globale
questo in qualche modo mette in allarme
l'esercito americano l'esercito
sovietico rischia di portare il mondo a
bordo di una guerra mondiale dopo una
serie infinita di peripezie il film si
conclude con un lieto fine e con il
supercomputer che lascia questo
messaggio nel momento in cui blocca
questa simulazione ma strano questo
gioco la guerra termonucleare globale
l'unica mossa vincente e non giocarla
perché noi ci facciamo una bella partita
a scacchi
quasi come se la guerra termonucleare
mai fosse capita è semplice non bisogna
giocarci perché non si può vincere ma
gli scacchi gli scacchi quelli sì sono
interessanti quelli sì sono complessi lì
come computer ti darei del filo da
torcere
in realtà si è dovuto aspettare fino al
1997 diversi anni dopo questo film
perché una macchina riuscì in questo
caso tip blu di ebm riuscisse a
sconfiggere il più forte degli umani a
questo gioco garry kasparov campione
mondiale e persona con il giocatore con
il più alto rating della storia in quel
momento
e sebbene si trattò di una sconfitta di
misura soltanto un punto su sei
disponibili questo fu forse il primo
momento il momento più eclatante in cui
una macchina ha sconfitto un uomo in un
gioco con noi pensiamo di relativo
all'intelligenza un gioco di
intelligenza e dopo gli scacchi questo è
stato solamente l'inizio
dopo gli scatti la ricerca si è spostata
a cercare di identificare giochi ancora
più complessi per il computer e si è
spostata verso il goal non so se lo
conoscete il goa un gioco molto diffuso
in asia molto semplice in cui giocatori
mettono delle pedine su una griglia
quello scopo di circondare dei territori
o circondare le pedine avversarie
catturandole alla fine della partita
chi ha circondato più territorio vince
nonostante le regole molto semplici è
considerato ancora più complicato degli
scacchi perché il numero di
configurazione numero di mosse
disponibili è enorme si calcola che sia
ancora più grande del numero di atomi
presenti all universo quindi non si
possono valutare ad una ad una le
possibilità si pensa che serva intuito
che serva comprensione che serve appunto
intelligenza per vincere e nel 2016 un
software al fago ha sconfitto lisi dle
il più grande
campione coreano di questo gioco e lo ha
fatto anche in una maniera nuova
originale mentre software che ha
sconfitto kasparov a scacchi era stato
programmato per conoscere tutte le
strategie dei più grandi campioni del
gioco
ecco questo software invece in qualche
modo ha imparato da solo con delle
tecniche che si chiamano di machine
learning machines der nixon una classe
di algoritmi che permettono ai
programmatori e di insegnare in qualche
modo ad un computer raggiungere un
obiettivo senza necessariamente
descriverli tutti i passi da fare ma
soltanto mostrandogli degli esempi
ecco questo software è stato programmato
per conoscere solamente le regole di
base del gioco e poi ha giocato un
numero infinito di partite contro se
stesso imparando dai propri successi dai
propri errori quali fossero le strategie
migliori per vincere senza bisogno che
qualcuno gli spiegasse ecco questo
software allenandosi da solo è riuscito
ad arrivare a giocare un livello
talmente alto che ha sconfitto tutti i
più grandi campioni di questo gioco e lo
ha fatto talvolta anche scegliendo delle
mosse nuove innovative anche difficili
da spiegare per un umano ecco il fatto
che una macchina impari a fare
un'attività che noi consideriamo di
intelligenza anche meglio dell'uomo ha
fatto pensare che siamo vicini a una
rivoluzione che presto ci saranno
macchine tanto intelligenti o forse
anche più intelligenti dell'uomo e ha
fatto ovviamente di tornare di moda
tutta una serie di discussioni su quale
possa essere l'effetto di queste
intelligenze artificiali sulla nostra
società e non vi dico niente di nuovo se
vi dico che alla fine tutte queste
discussioni non importa di cosa stiamo
parlando non importa di quale
applicazione finiscono per arrivare al
pensiero che queste intelligenze
artificiali si rivoltino contro l'uomo e
possano essere dannose distrutto
distruttive per la nostra società ecco
io credo che dovremmo emanciparci da
questa paura che dovremmo liberarci da
questo modo di pensare a un futuro così
catastrofico perché credo che i
focalizzarci su queste cose non ci
permetta di vedere razionalmente cosa
sta realmente succedendo in questo
momento
intanto una cosa che forse ha fatto
sorridere qualcuno qualche anno fa
questa intelligenza artificiale non sono
come intelligenti
qui si ri mi sono ferito molto
gravemente chiamami un'ambulanza da oggi
in poi ti chiamerò con il nome
un'ambulanza d'accordo quindi insomma un
intelligenza che capisce qualcosa ma non
capisce proprio come noi
per di più forse questa paura di
terminator non ci permette di accorgersi
che in questo momento ci sono tante
altre rudimentali intelligenze
artificiali che prendono delle decisioni
relative alla nostra vita siamo sicuri
di conoscere di capire come
interagiscono con noi
lasciate che vi faccio un esempio questa
è la sezione delle notizie interessanti
per me che il mio telefonino mi ha
mostrato alcuni giorni fa cosa succede
qui dietro c'è un algoritmo di machine
learning che prende tutti i dati che lui
conosce su di me quindi l'età alle
ricerche che ho fatto le applicazioni
che uso e le usa le confronta con quelle
di altri utenti per classificarle in uno
specifico segmento di pubblico ed armi
dei suggerimenti personalizzati sulle
notizie che mi possono piacere e come
vedete qui il mio segmento è proprio
quello dei nerd quelli a cui piacciono
le
il computer le notizie di attività
infatti ficiale di scienza e
naturalmente come ogni nerd che si
rispetti notizie su game of thrones e
notizie su star wars non possono mancare
l'algoritmo l'unica cosa che fa è
cercare di ottimizzare queste notizie
perché io ci clicchi sopra non si
scomoda a mostrarmi delle cose che non
mi possono interessare ma cosa stava
succedendo nel mondo nel frattempo
questa era la prima pagina di repubblica
terza notizia mi stavo perdendo la
nascita del royal baby 6.000
condivisione ha notizia importantissima
come avrei fatto a perderla
ecco in qualche modo questo algoritmo ha
codificato il pregiudizio che ai nerd
come me non interessi il gossip e quindi
questa notizia manco me l'ha mostrata
non mi ha dato neanche l'opportunità di
cambiare questo stereotipo mi ha chiuso
nelle scelte ha creato una profezia che
si autoavvera in cui la mia libertà di
scelta delle notizie è stata limitata e
guidata rinforzando quindi lo stereotipo
su in earth
finché si tratta di gossip e vabbè
pazienza ma cosa succede se questi
stessi algoritmi scelgono le notizie che
ci vengono mostrate nei social network
cosa succede se questi che se l'unico
obiettivo che hanno questi algoritmi e
quello che io clicchi sulla notizia così
l'inserzionista paga del denaro
cosa succede se mi vengono mostrati
solamente contenuti con i quali io sono
già d'accordo discussioni commenti che
non mettono in discussione la mia idea
sono in grado di abituarmi a
confrontarmi con idee diverse
sono in grado di cambiare idea è questo
quello che vogliamo con la nostra città
la nostra società ma soprattutto come
utente sono consapevole che la mia
libertà di informazione è stata limitata
che voglio dire se sono interessato al
gossip
la notizia del royal baby devo andare a
cercare da qualche altra parte
e cosa succede se le notizie che mi
vengono presentate sono addirittura
false d'altronde un social network non
ha gli stessi obblighi professionali
legali deontologici di un quotidiano non
deve fare informazione corretta
ecco ma proviamo a spingerci oltre
cosa succede se questi stessi algoritmi
vengono utilizzati per decidere chi
invitare ad un'intervista di lavoro
molte compagnie usano software
automatici per filtrare i candidati e
quasi tutti questi software automatici
sono sistemi di machine swing che
imparano dai dati precedenti relativi
all'assunzione di quell azienda e ci
sono molte ricerche che dimostrano che i
sistemi già in uso perpetuano le
discriminazioni che ci sono nei dati di
quell azienda cioè se un'azienda in
passato ha assunto più maschi che
femmine
perché faccio affettuato questa
discriminazione
il sistema imparerà a preferire i
candidati uomini rispetto a candidati
donne quindi perpetuando questa
discriminazione di genere
questa è una cosa che è già successa
amazon ha riportato un problema simile
nei loro sistemi alcuni anni fa a
spingiamoci ancora un passo più avanti
cosa succede se usiamo questi sistemi
per valutare quale sia il rischio che io
commetta un crimine in europa diverse
nazioni stanno pensando di utilizzare
sistemi automatici nell'ambito legale
negli stati uniti molte quote di
giustizia già usano dei software per
valutare il livello di rischio di
recidiva delle persone incriminate
ecco questi software sono anch'essi
software che imparano software the
machine che imparano dai dati
generalmente le dati relativi alla
popolazione carceraria e siccome
purtroppo negli stati uniti è molto più
semplice finire in galera se si fa parte
di una minoranza etnica questi software
imparano a classificare come più
rischiose le persone appartenenti a 10
determinate minoranze
ci sono diverse ricerche che hanno
mostrato che una stragrande maggioranza
di questi software prendere delle
decisioni chiaramente a sfavore delle
persone di colore
ecco ci sono tantissimi altri esempi che
si possono fare e in tutti questi casi
non c'è nessuna intelligenza artificiale
sfuggita al controllo dell'uomo non c'è
nessun terminator
ci sono dei sistemi automatici che hanno
sostituito delle decisioni che prima
venivano prese da un uomo ma senza
essere tenute a rispettare gli stessi
standard etici che l'uomo deve
rispettare
sono decisioni spesso discriminatorie
spesso in trasparenti spesso difficili
da spiegare per le stesse persone che
hanno
scritto questi algoritmi sono decisioni
che non sono in linea con i valori
fondanti della nostra società
ecco di questo dovremo avere paura non
di terminator
vorrei comunque provare a dare una
visione positiva un esempio positivo
partendo proprio dai giochi che sono la
mia grande passione
questi due campioni che hanno dedicato
tutta la propria vita a conoscere i
segreti degli scacchi e del go e poi
sono stati sconfitti da un intelligenza
artificiale sono mica smesso di giocare
anzi hanno detto che grazie a questi
software hanno capito meglio il gioco
hanno capito meglio il motivo per cui
loro giocano hanno capito meglio le
strategie che dovrò adottano durante le
loro partite sono diventati dei
giocatori migliori sono diventate i
giocatori più consapevoli queste
macchine hanno esteso la loro umanità
non l'hanno compressa ecco io voglio
sperare che anziché a diciamo all'alba
della distruzione dell'umanità da parte
di un artificial intelligence sfuggita
di mano ecco forse siamo invece all'alba
di una sorta di nuovo rinascimento
forse utilizzando questi software
possiamo riflettere su di noi cercare di
capire quali sono i valori che ci
rendono veramente umani cercare di
pretendere che questi valori siano
inseriti nei software che prendono
decisioni al posto nostro
usare questi software per costruire
tutti insieme una società che sia più
giusta per tutti e sono convinto che lo
possiamo fare se ci diamo tutti quanti
da fare se partecipiamo al dibattito
pubblico
se richiediamo un maggiore trasparenza
maggiore responsabilità nell'uso di
questi sistemi seri chiediamo anche
delle conseguenze per usi sbagliati di
questi sistemi
se pensi che ci spingiamo fino a
chiedere più ricerca pubblica per
esempio su questi temi in maniera che
non siano appannaggio solo delle aziende
interessate al profitto
abbiamo l'occasione di creare di
costruire lei ai come bene pubblico al
servizio di tutti e per tutti
ecco io penso che ci sia un sacco di
lavoro da fare e che dovremmo cominciare
a farlo tutti quanti insieme
oppure possiamo aspettare
forse possiamo aspettare con
intelligenza artificiale lo faccia al
posto nostro
[Applauso]